We have a full course on Swift syntax.
If you're new to the Swift
programming language,
I highly recommend going through it.
For now, I'm going to attempt to
give you a quick intro into Swift
in under five minutes.
It is just the basics
that you need to know.
And it assumes you've seen some
programming language concepts before.
There are just four key concepts to
understand before we can start coding,
variables, control flow,
classes, and functions.
Hopefully, you're watching
this video as Xcode downloads.
Ready?
Here we go.
Variables, if you want to
declare a variable in Swift,
the var keyword let's you do that.
As an example, here we have
a variable called x of type Int, and
we're setting its value to 42.
Note the semi-colons are not needed.
Do you see something
else that's a bit odd?
That's right.
The type of this variable
comes after the variable name,
different than most other languages.
The reason for this is that Swift can
infer the type of the variable, so
in most cases,
you can leave the type completely off.
For example,
here I could just make x equal to 42.
Now something else you're going to
encounter in your code is a constant.
For example,
here we have y that is a constant
of type int with a value of 100.
Swift has inferred the type int because
we're setting it to an int value.
The next type of variable that you
need to deal with are strings.
They're easy, too.
Let me show you an example.
Here we have a variable of type string,
and I'm setting its value to Hello.
Moving on to control flow,
the only item that you need to know for
control flow is if statements.
If statements can determine what
branch or path your code should take.
As an example, if i put something
like this, we can take one path if
x is less than 50 and a different path
if x is greater than or equal to 50.
If we want to see what path is chosen,
we can open the debug console and
take a look at that.
That's this middle button
here on the upper right.
We're going to cover loops and
the powerful switch statements in
the later part of this course.
Classes are objects which
allow you to store values and
have functions that
operate on those values.
The really interesting part of
classes is that they have inheritance.
And therefore,
they can carry forward any values and
functionalities from their parent,
called a superclass.
If we look at this view
controller definition here,
we can see that it inherits
from UIViewController.
And any instances or class functions
that I have would go here in the middle,
where I have these two
green comment lines.
You can declare class variables
that live in the class and
functions that exist in every
instance of that class.
Just remember two things
about classes in Swift.
Everything in between the curly braces
for the class is inside the class and
available to any function in the class.
And the UIViewController here is
what this class inherits from.
And it will be our hint
where to look for for
built in functionality,
that is, what functionality
our ViewController class inherits
from its parent UIViewController.
Functions are a way to encompass
code and make it more reusable.
Functions start with the keyword func,
followed by a name, then any parameters,
and the return type.
Here's an example of
the most basic function.
It takes no parameters,
and it returns nothing.
It just prints out Hello.
We can call this function by
doing something like this.
We can see Hello here is printed
out in the debug console.
We can also have functions
that take a parameter.
For example, if you wanted to
print Hello in many languages,
we could write a function like this.
printHelloMessage that takes
in a hello message string.
Here we just simply
called it helloString.
It's of type string.
And then we print that message.
To call this function,
we'd simply do something like this.
printHelloMessage, and pass it
the message that we want it to send,
in this case,
a hello greeting in Portuguese.
So here we have the hello greeting in
English with the regular function,
taking in no parameters,
returning nothing.
And we have the Portuguese greeting, for
the function it takes in one parameter
string, it also doesn't return anything.
Just simply runs the print command.
That's just a little bit of Swift
that you need to know before we
dive into Xcode in iOS development.
I've included a link below
on our Swift refresher and
other resources if you
want to learn more.
Hopefully you'll finish downloading and
installing Xcode.
When you're ready, let's go about
creating your first iOS app.